tous les 28 jours le rituel est le même
prix par ses vêtements son équipement et
ses provisions pour quatre semaines de
boulot
l'homme de 73 ans est gardien de phare
depuis 50 ans oneapp à me défaire le
personnel a été réduit dit il seulement
dans la baie de fundy il comptait
environ soixante dix gardiens pour une
trentaine de fort lorsqu'il a commencé
sa carrière
ils ne sont maintenant que quatre
gardiens les vieux pirate avec des
jambes de bois en haut du phare au beau
milieu de la tempête s'est tiré de
hollywood rigole-t-il
le gardien a probablement l'occasion de
photographier le faire plus souvent
qu'il ne sciera s'étagent s'effectue de
la maison des hommes de fort et consiste
principalement à s'assurer que la
lumière la corne de brume et les
équipements radio fonctionne mais son
rôle est plus grand tous les jours d'été
un bateau canadien et un américain avec
à bord pas plus de 15 passagers y
débarque lille match aller c'est un
refuge exceptionnel d'oiseaux migrateurs
surtout des acides et parmi eux les
petits pingouins et les macareux attire
les touristes
c'est le canada qui gère mais que les
etats-unis disent que ça leur appartient
mais c'est très très unique en allemand
alors de quoi vivre sans la cepam à une
fois dans une ville qu'on viendra ici
comme l'été est la période de
nidification et les crucial que la
limite de visiteurs soit respectée et
que ceux-ci se confine dans les caches
de lille pour photographier les oiseaux
c'était vraiment
émouvant de les voir si proches
commandants des mondiaux de clichy c'est
là ma spéciale le gaz il paraît donc est
ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'abus
[Musique]
une tâche essentielle toute l'année les
gardiens de phares sont aussi les yeux
et les oreilles des scientifiques
lorsqu'ils ne sont pas également
conscient qu'il est en poste pour
veiller aux intérêts du canada pour
jeunes pas
ils étaient moins de spectacle peu de
gens ont la chance d'observer tous les
jours
les spectacles auxquels il a l'intention
d'assister encore longtemps
même après 50 ans de carrière il veut
qu'elle se poursuivre encore plusieurs
années et simon tamboura du canada sur
l'île match à nice